scp 682 versus a ton of liquid nitrogen
after trying and failing to kill scp-682
via anomalous means dr carlson wished to
return to basics and try some
non-anomalous murder methods for
bringing an end to this nasty lizard the
682 tissue sample was successful it was
frozen and shattered when struck with a
hammer exactly as intended however when
682 proper was doused with liquid
nitrogen its body remained frozen and
dormant for about 10 minutes then it
began increasing its body temperature
until it was thawed but it didn't stop
there it kept increasing its body
temperature until it was so hot that the
walls of the containment chamber began
to melt dr carlson noted
interesting it retained the adaptation
even after it was no longer necessary
maybe we should be more careful
scp-682 versus scp-294
the hard-to-destroy reptile versus the
coffee machine could this supernatural
keurig brew up a final victory over this
ordinary reptile researchers got the
machine to dispense
scp-682 killer and poured it onto a
tissue sample the sample crumbled into a
fine powder when it made contact with
the liquid so they cumulatively brewed
up a liter of the stuff and poured it on
the actual
scp-682 the affected areas decayed and
crumbled just like in the test and when
scp-682 was placed back into its acid
tank the area is completely dissolved
the researchers felt incredibly hopeful
believing that if a large enough
quantity of scp-682 killer can be
synthesized it may actually live up to
its name we'll let you know as soon as
they try it again with a venti order
scp-682 vs scp-923
can this terrifying mind-melting
satellite finally drive scp-682 off the
edge foundation researchers damaged
scp-682 heavily and took it out to an
isolated field in kansas in order to
find out
scp-923 fired down at 682 with its beam
set to intensity level 75 known to have
devastating effects against the minds of
its victims when the blast was unleashed
682 began screaming and howling
obscenities at the sky and the
foundation then its body began to adapt
growing glowing nodes that fired out its
own beam similar to scp-923's blasts
driving the observing foundation
employees completely insane the test was
considered such a failure that one of
the lead researchers on the scp-682
termination project threatened to do
something redacted to whoever organized
it
scp-682 versus extremely high
temperatures could the monstrous hard to
destroy reptile finally be roasted to
death in a superheated room the
researchers at the scp foundation hope
so they locked it in a special chamber
and increased the temperature to truly
immense proportions but rather than
melting as the researchers had hoped it
developed a car pace of solid helium
which defended it from the heat even
worse was that the car pace remained in
place even as the room was reduced back
to safe temperatures when personnel were
sent in to inspect the creature the
carapace abruptly shattered and exploded
all over the room shredding everyone
nearby 682 had baited its victims inside
and gotten a little payback for the
extreme sauna session
scp-682 vs scp-3922
who would win in this matchup between
the indestructible reptile and the tv
reality filter 3922 is a small cylinder
that when placed near a television will
alter the content of any fictional
material being played to include a
battalion of heavily armed soldiers who
proceed to arrest the characters in the
film and try them for their crimes the
foundation introduced 3922 to security
footage of 682 the tape was then altered
into a 72-hour military epic in which a
coalition of soldiers all played by
deceased actors attempted to terminate
682 over the course of the film the film
ends with a final remaining soldier
played by patrick swayze alongside
several gigantic primates staring down
682 and preparing to duke it out once
and for all before a 2b continued title
card is displayed talk about a sequel
hook scp 682 vs scp-117
the hard to destroy reptile versus the
perfect multi-tool but can this
ultra-convenient and somewhat vampiric
gadget finally macgyver this nasty
lizard out of existence the foundation
started with a sample test using tissue
extracted from 682's back and a d-class
in charge of holding the multi-tool the
test looked promising 117 produced a
number of pneumatic hammers and pounded
the 682 tissue sample into a fine slurry
then disintegrated the slurry into
nothingness with particle beam weaponry
leaving the d-class it was being handled
by with an almost deadly mineral
deficiency however as you can probably
guessed the test against the whole 682
lizard wasn't so successful rather than
attacking 682 117 produced a device that
teleported itself and the d-class using
it away killing the d-class in the
process test failed
scp-682 vs scp-170
can the ultimate molecular super glue
pin the hard to destroy reptile down for
good the scp-170 glue was laced onto a
series of metal chains with the hope of
confining rather than executing the
monster the tissue sample was promising
and things proceeded from there 682 was
sedated and wrapped with chains which
were then connected to the ground
initially when 682 woke up it thrashed
around and tried to escape however its
attempts were futile but before
researchers could start patting
themselves on the back 682 began to grow
until it reached such a size that the
chains simply popped off the leading
theory as to how this worked wasn't that
it hadn't technically grown but
increased the distance between its
particles shattering the molecular bond
created by scp-170
scp-682 versus scp-049
the hard to destroy reptile is certainly
a pretty pestilent creature but would
the mild-mannered plague doctor be able
to cure our world of its presence
scp-049 slowly approached the creature
seeming equal parts fascinated and
frightened it murmured the disease
appears to not affect only humans to
itself he closed in to get a better look
and tried to grab 682 but the reptile
immediately growled and swiped at 0-4-9
the doctor narrowly dodged taking any
real damage but the experience shook him
he seemed panicked and a little
emotionally disturbed at his own request
he was escorted back to his containment
chamber poor guy
scp-682 vs scp-2855
they say that money makes the world go
round but can mr money put the reptile
underground
scp-2855 or mr money is part of dr
wondertainment's little mr series his
ability is having whatever capabilities
his buyer believes he has so he was sold
to a member of the o5 council as a man
who can permanently destroy
scp-682 and will do so immediately upon
completion of this transaction however
this didn't happen instead he
disappeared for an hour during which
time as cp 682 seemed to show no ill
effects he later reappeared next to the
council member dazed in experiencing
memory loss with a note that read oops
doctor one detainment offers this
sincerest of apologies for this
unanticipated malfunction of your mr
money tm we will be working to correct
this error in future products goodbye
scp-682 vs scp-093
our dimension can't seem to keep the
hard to destroy reptile down but maybe
the dimension that scp-093 the red sea
object offers us access to across the
mirror plane might have better luck the
object passed around scp-682 until it
turned green and affixed itself to a
nearby mirror purposefully selected to
be big enough to allow scp-682 through
when it refused to enter the mirror was
brought over 682 was pushed in and then
the mirror was shattered however later
on the mirror anomalously put itself
back together and scp-682 was pushed
back out because of course he was
scp-682 commented of his time on the
other side i am not very amused
scp-682 vs scp-5871
could the knife that retroactively
erases its victims from the timeline
finally remove the hard to destroy
reptile from our past present and future
scp-682 was bound in place by restraints
to prevent it from escaping and a
researcher using
scp-5871 slashed it erasing it from
existence from that point on a ck-class
reality restructuring event occurred and
post restructure researchers were unable
to find any traces of scp-682
it seemed almost like it never existed
however soon after this the effects were
reversed by scp-682's adapting abilities
682 returned to reality then the test we
just described was erased from existence
as well as scp-5871
scp-682 vs scp-101
could the hungry bag finally be the
anomaly that doesn't find the to destroy
reptile too tough to swallow
scp-101 the hungry bag is a small tooth
lined bag seemingly connected to a
limitless pocket dimension capable of
devouring almost anything dr lee roy
carlson suggested it might be perfect to
finish off 682 after it was reduced in
size by another anomaly so after scp-682
was shrunk down by a confrontation with
scp-165-1
its tiny body was thrown into the gaping
maw of scp-108
and swallowed up later however scp-101
began to gurgle for an extended period
after a prolonged period of discomfort
it belched up the tiny scp-682
which later returned to its normal size
scp-682 vs scp-3042
could the ultimate case of puppy love be
the force to counteract scp-682's
reptilian hatred let's take a look and
see
scp-3042 is a small but superpowered dog
that bonds with one individual at a time
and basically gradually loves them to
death with constant and unyielding
affection its latest favorite person was
eaten by scp-682
causing scp-3042 to imprint on the
monster as a replacement however this
was disastrous as scp-682 immediately
attacked the tiny dog causing it to run
away in fear
scp-3042 charged through a nearby wall
thankfully making a hole too small for
scp-682 to escape through and imprinted
on a nearby guard another test
failed
scp-682 vs
scp-407 could the song of genesis alter
the hard to destroy reptile out of
existence finally making it true music
to the scp foundation's ears at 25
seconds 682 did not seem at all soothed
by the music at 45 seconds the
creature's wounds from a previous test
healed rapidly and it made a
high-pitched noise at one minute 25
seconds 682 screamed and its mouth began
to fill with a white foamy substance at
1 minute 55 seconds it swallowed this
same substance and started choking
however at 2 minutes 35 seconds it
squirted all the substance out of its
mouth in a powerful jet and at 3 minutes
55 seconds 682 remained unconscious for
five minutes to heal and then awoke
utterly unaffected by the song of
genesis
scp-682 vs scp-165
could the hard-to-destroy reptile
finally be devoured by the combined
forces of the creeping hungry sands of
tool a large
scp-165 sample was placed beneath a trap
door with scp-682 positioned above it
when the monster was dropped into the
hill of teeming flesh-eating mites they
began devouring it it was engulfed in
the dunes and remained there for 10
minutes before the dunes ceased activity
and a much smaller version of scp-680
crawled out the fire eaters were called
in to blast both and returned 682 to its
containment chamber in all likelihood
682 had admitted a pesticide that killed
off the mites while a smaller version of
itself hid inside its own skull
until it was safe to emerge and attempt
to escape
scp-682 vs scp-067
while this particular cross test was
never expected to destroy or even harm
the hard to destroy reptile researchers
figured that this all telling fountain
pen might glean valuable information
about the monster
scp-067 is a pen that causes people to
compulsively write or draw about
themselves when the pen was given to
scp-682 it was horribly surprised when
it began drawing a complex image on the
floor when the image was done it threw
the pen across the room the resulting
picture was a self-portrait of scp-682
sitting atop a legion of dead roman
soldiers marked as the 9th legion which
had historically mysteriously
disappeared they may have been no closer
to defeating scp-682
but at least they solved that mystery
scp-682 versus scp-1437
could dropping 682 in a hole to another
place finally get rid of it for good to
begin the test 682 was thrown into 1437
at one hour three minutes 23 seconds
scp-682 was expelled from 1437 in the
shape of a large glass object filled
with a red blood-like liquid an on-site
bulldozer pushed it back down the hole
at 13 hours 12 minutes 7 seconds scp-682
was expelled from the hole again in the
form of a round mechanical device that
released a dangerous gas and had a mouth
full of gold teeth the bulldozer pushed
it back down at 27 hours 20 minutes
scp-682 was propelled out of 1437 it had
returned to its original shape with the
exception of a larger body shorter snout
and a variety of weapons embedded in its
body
scp-682 vs scp-938
can this electrical entity provide an
adequate shock to 682 system
scp-682 was placed in the containment
chamber attached to site-7 an electric
device was brought into the room and
routed into scp-938
the device increased in electrical
voltage to the point that it damaged
scp-682
causing burns to its body and paralyzing
it for one hour at this point it
regained motion capabilities and shot
electricity from its spine through its
head then it lost consciousness though
it was still breathing and remained that
way for several days as its body
recovered not quite as electrifying as
the foundation had hoped so it appeared
the researcher for this test dr carly
did at least note that electrical or
mine-based scps did tend to keep scp-682
immobilized longer than physical or
chemical attacks
scp-682 vs scp-858
could gravity's rainbow finally clear
the dark cloud of the unkillable reptile
and bring sunny skies to the scp
foundation a tissue sample from 682
repelled from earth's gravity at a speed
of 9.8 meters per second was destroyed
by scp-858
when scp-682 was exposed to 858 it began
to fall away from the earth's surface at
the same rate as the sample it reached
858 but it did not disappear it hit some
sort of invisible barrier and its body
appeared to be slowly boiling this
continued until the reptile had lost 50
percent of its body mass when half of
its body was gone 682 suddenly sprouted
a pair of wings similar to those of
petriosaurs in addition to an array of
air bladders that allowed it to fly
perpendicular to scp-858's gravity
scp-682 versus scp-539
could the perfect distraction take 682's
attention away from the one thing it
cares about hatred a member of d-class
personnel was sent into
scp-682's containment chamber carrying
scp-539 then the doors were shut behind
them terrified that scp-682 would kill
them the d-class threw scp-539 early in
an attempt to distract it as soon as
scp-539 was thrown the site experienced
a system malfunction in the containment
chamber an acid pump was activated
during this malfunction trapping scp-682
for approximately 20 minutes before it
was deactivated by site maintenance
staff by the time staff reached the
containment chamber 85 of 682's body had
been destroyed
scp-539 was found nearby and the d-class
was completely gone three hours later
scp-682 was completely recovered plus an
additional pair of legs grown during the
healing process